enter into the eternal divine order of God to place my absolute nothingness in the heart
of the most holy Trinity. To give to my God the joy of fulfilling the purpose of my existence
by doing all the acts of my life through the immaculate heart of my mother Mary and in the
divine will of God. And in the same manner may I live, pray, act, eat, walk, sleep and do
everything. May my soul be devoid of any other longings, wants or desires and may you my beloved
divine will do with me whatever you want or desire. All I ask is that you bind me to your
most holy will so intimately that I may never swear from carrying out what I know to be your
good pleasure and that I remain so docile to the movements of your divine will that you never
perceive even a breath of resistance in my soul to your requests of me. Come divine will with all
the angels and saints, especially my sweet mother Mary, to touch my forehead, to imprint on it the
holy spirit and infuse in me true light so that I may understand the truths and the good that are
in these writings and prayers. Amen. So I want to take up in September the 16th 1925. Jesus was
always the same in his pains. Now one of the things that Jesus is going to tell us now is one of these
signs of a saint and that is they're not up and down. They're not explosive one minute and then
patient on another. No, there's an evenness right across the board. Okay, so Louisa said my days are
more bitter because of the long privations of my sweet Jesus. His will alone is left to me
as a precious inheritance of the many visits that he made to my poor soul. And now I have been left
alone forgotten by the one who formed my life so much so that it seemed to me this is the first time
that Louisa actually acknowledges something that Jesus has already said about her and that is that
they have already reached inseparability. This is her first time to acknowledge it. That it seemed
to me that we were fused together and that neither could he be without me nor I without him. Now I
want to give you a couple of scriptures because the scriptures are all over the place here. First of
all I want to give you for the privations Philippians chapter 1 verses 20 to 26 where you have Paul
dealing with the same problem. He couldn't be without me nor I him. I want to give you John 14 20 to 21
you and me and I and you both completely won. And so Louisa continues and while I think
where did the one go who loved me so much? What have I done that he has left me? Now she deals with
this so frequently that you just wonder you know my temptation is to say Louisa when you get a mirror
you're telling the same thing over and over and over again and the Lord has told her
ad nauseam that he cannot leave her because they are in fact inseparable.
Okay but she doesn't get it because in her mind she wants to see him not just experience him in
her heart and in her soul she actually wants the visitations she's had before and she's not willing
to let it go. I find that rather interesting in somebody advanced in divine will. At Jesus she
says come back come back for I can take no more. Now she's demanding the visual that she has had
before and while I would like to abandon myself to sorrow and think of my great misfortune of having
lost the one in whom I had enclosed all my hopes and all my happiness the holy divine will imposes
itself on me. Now this is very interesting notice I would have liked and then because she's in this
state in which she is completely given to the divine will and the divine will is raining in her
he can impose his will on her so he imposes himself on her making me follow the course of my
accent his adorable will. Now what you're getting here is regardless of how I feel whether I'm sick
or well whether I'm sad or happy whether I think things are going my way or not I am being told
to continue on an even path with all my prayer and intercession. I don't do it just because I
like it and I don't stop because I don't feel like it and she says the divine will almost prevents me
from grieving more for being without my only good so the divine will doesn't want her indulging in
grief and sorrow and she's done quite a bit of that in the volumes up to now he's all the time he's
pushing her higher and higher to be like Jesus in everything. So she said I remain as though petrified
intrepid that means she will persevere regardless all alone without the slightest comfort either
from heaven or from earth. A very important thing you'd need to put in the margin there is crucified
in the divine will. It's not the way human nature wants to go. One of the things that is very clear
when you read the Gospels is that Jesus could not be provoked by the scribes and the Pharisees
and the Herodians and the priests and the Sadducees who tried to get him to do this that and the other
no matter what they did no matter what provocation he was given either during his ministry or during
his passion they could not get him to do something he didn't want to do and they could not get him to
say something he didn't want to say. He was sovereignly free and this is where we're going in divine will
we have to become completely free. First of all free of ourselves free of the world free of the
influence of the evil one so that we can in fact give a very pure very holy adoration to God and
service to God. So, Louisa continues while I was in this state I was thinking about various pains of
the passion of Jesus so she herself is in pain and in a crucified state she would naturally think of
the crucifixion of Jesus and Jesus said my daughter in all of my pains I was always the same this is
terribly important I never changed watch this now because he's the model my gaze was always sweet
oh dear when things go against us we can show in our eyes and in our facial expressions
that we do not like it one little bit thank you very much my gaze was always sweet my face was
always serene now you get that so frequently in the hours of the passion that no matter what they
did to him he was always serene and it was one of the reasons why they people torturing him blindfolded
him because they couldn't take that incredible gaze of love he said my words were always calm
so no to this excited stuff when you're upset my words were always calm and they were always
dignified now here you see somebody in complete control of their own being and completely expressing
the will of God for us this is loving your neighbor as yourself at a level that we can hardly understand
it's fantastic in my whole person I had such equality of manners this is the spiritual balance
inside of us that if they had wanted to recognize me as their redeemer merely by the way of seeing
me always the same always balanced they would have recognized me it's true that as they continued on
in the passion my pains were so many as to eclipse me in other words Jesus looked ugly on the outside
because of what they did to him but internally he was always the same
unfortunately human beings look at the outside
so it's true that my pains were so many as to eclipse me and surround me like many clouds but
this says nothing after the heat of the pains I would reappear in the midst of my enemies like
a majestic sun and that's what louisa says several times in the hours of the passion
I would appear among them with my usual serenity and with the same manners always equal and always
peaceful there's an extraordinary picture now considering that he's tortured almost beyond recognition
to be always the same is only of God human nature is not expressing itself
to be always the same is how you recognize the true children of God there's your model
there's your model the way that is always equal to itself this is this fantastic balance
in your emotional life your mental life your spiritual life your physical life this complete
balance the way that is always equal to itself impresses the divine character on the soul
and reveals the operating of creatures as pure now pure means not mixed with anything else
and very particularly not mixed with self not mixed with any selfish motivations or attitudes
and not mixed with self will so it's pure and holy and therefore pure and holy it's worthy of God
let me give you there Hebrews 1214 that i've given to you so often nothing on holy or on
where they can enter the presence of God on the other hand a changing character of the creatures
that we're going to talk about how the flesh reacts is a sign of passions of roar within the human
heart that tyrannize it in such a way as to show an unpleasant character also on the outside
so what screaming and roaring inside expresses itself on the outside
and it displeases everyone i love the everyone he doesn't say it displeases God it displeases
everyone you live with as well because you know yourself that when people get angry and upset and
everything it doesn't please anybody it displeases everyone he says therefore i recommend to you
that you be always the same now watch this always the same with God with the Lord
in other words you're not complaining and moaning and giving out and murmuring and blah blah blah
like the the Israelites did as they dragged their heens all the way through the desert
no you to be always the same with me and always the same as far as i'm concerned is
not my will but thine be done that has to be our motto or put it the other way be it done on to me
according to your word but i think that not my will is helpful if you're on the way it's all right
for a blessed lady she was there i recommend that you all be always the same with me always the same
with yourself that's very interesting now that you're not allowing allowing yourself even in your
private moments to have any outbursts and very often that problem is in your mind where you allow
thoughts to run all over the place in your mind and you may think oh it's not affecting anybody
else it is it's affecting everybody you have to be always the same with me with yourself and with
others this is very interesting but it is a fact that if you have conquered yourself to the point
where there is balance emotionally and spiritually there when others provoke you you will not give an
unbalanced reaction i remember seeing a sticker on the back of a car one day and it read you hit me
i hit you there's the world anger for anger displeasure for displeasure hatred for hatred
reaction for reaction that's not of the kingdom and it's most definitely not in the divine will
domain and jesus said you're to be always the same even when you are in pain and even in my very
privation now you go back to the beginning of this message and she said i wanted to feel such and
such but the divine will impose herself and so jesus is saying that he doesn't want her uh moaning
about her privations even though he himself acknowledges that it is a martyrdom for her
he says the unchanging character must be indelible in you the immutability of god touching the creature
and even though the pains of my privation knock you down and form the clouds of sorrow inside and
outside of you your unchanging manners will be light which will dispel these clouds and will reveal how
though hidden i always dwell in you jesus says if you give this response to absolutely everything
not only will everybody else know that god is living and working in you but you yourself will
acknowledge it as well so i want to give you one krentians three sixteen know you not that you are
the temple of the living god and that god dwells in you now in the next paragraph uh the subject is
what is the message that silence gives silence can give many messages and of course it starts off
with louisa saying to jesus why aren't you talking you know after this she said i continue to think
about the pains of the passion of my adorable jesus with the nail of his privation in my heart
now notice how quickly she obeys she has been told to keep this balance there
and she goes ahead and continues her meditations regardless of the nail as she calls it in her heart
and my beloved jesus made himself seen in my interior all taciturn and so afflicted us to
her i was pity now this is our eight-eighth volume so we should know why he is like this but louisa asks
him why he is like this as if it has never happened before she's living so completely in the present
moment she doesn't realize she's asked this fifty times before and she said my love why are you so
silent it seems to me that you don't want to tell me anything anymore i love the way she says
things like that and he's revealing things to her all the time nor do you want to confide your secrets
or your pains any longer and jesus old goodness but afflicted told me my daughter being silent expresses
something greater than speech think about that i've told many people over the years that my preferred
experience is the sound of silence absolutely love it it's totally profound you can enter into
the very heart of the universe and feel it one with god and with the whole of creation absolutely
the whole of humanity at a level that they wouldn't understand so being silent expresses
something greater than speech to be silent is a the decision of one not wanting to be dissuaded
keep silence so so this is very particular to the relationship between jesus and louisa he said
i don't want to be dissuaded so i don't speak don't tell you and if i don't tell you then you can't
fight me you see secondly it's the silence of a father with the beloved son of his while in the
midst of other unruly sons of the beloved son of course is louisa and the unruly ones are the ones
outside and it is a sign that he wants to strike the perverted ones now he's been telling her this
since volume one well maybe not volume one i'll try volume two on it he's been telling her
that if he comes to her silent and taciturn it's because justice is operating in the in the world
and when he leaves her in the privations that exactly is the explanation as well
but she comes back to it time out of number not really accepting it do you think it's nothing that
i don't come to you and that i'm sparing in sharing my pains with you and my daughter it isn't nothing
on the contrary it's something very great as i do not come to you my justice comes filled with
scourges in order to strike man so much so that all the past evils earthquakes wars will be nothing
compared to the evils which will come this is 1925 and the evils ever coming is world war two
initially and world war three which is on the way we're looking at the first rumblings of world war
three at the moment so it'll be nothing by comparison with the evils that will come and to the great
war the great war was world war two and the revolution that they are preparing sins are so many
that men do not deserve that i share my pains with you and in order to free them from the scourges
that are deserved so she wants to query why and she has said it to him you're not sharing anything
with me anymore and you said but people don't deserve it i'm not going to make you suffer for
no reason they don't deserve it so that means this is only 1925 i can't imagine what he would say today
therefore he said have patience my will will make up for my visible presence in you because
the divine will is the essence of god even though i remain hidden in you one of the things we need
to wake up in the world today is that god is present but hidden Satan is present but hidden
and there's a very powerful remnant in all countries that i know of present but hidden
the whole spiritual warfare that's going on in the world today is under the radar
take note it's extremely important the task you have in participating on god side
so he said i'm present but i'm hidden inside of you and if it were not so he said you could not
have kept up the pace of doing your usual rounds in my will you just absolutely couldn't it is i
who though hidden do them within you you know the story of the the footprints yeah she's being
carried and you follow the one whom you do not see i want to give you revelation 14 4 then we
follow the lamb where so ever he goes however once my justice is completed in fulfilling the
discourages i will be with you like before therefore wait for me isiah 40 31 wait for me
and don't fear he's now going to show her what's coming so i want to give you amos 3 7 that the
lord doesn't do anything without telling the prophets first why they were saying this i found
myself outside of myself in the midst of the world in almost all nations one could see preparations
for war this is only 1925 and they were already preparing for war i challenged somebody the other
day to go on wikipedia and look for world war one and when you go down through that look for world
war two and when you go down to that look for world war three wake up they're preparing for war
i could see preparations for war i could see new more tragic ways of fighting so she saw
new weapons of war which of course they used in world war two which struck flight at the mere
sight and then the great human blindness which becoming yet more blind acted like a beast whoops
now that blindness was prophesied in isiah 6 9 to 10 the people would be so blind that they would
see and see and never see they would hear and hear and never understand because they had blinded
their eyes and shut their ears for fear that they would hear but they didn't their hearts became
like stone and when human beings become like stone they actually become like beasts now what do you
mean by beast is a ravenous beast i don't want to give you a revelation 13 for that we'll be
visiting that in two days time and the behavior that was done in the concentration camps in the
second world war was certainly beastly they will behave like a beast not like a man and because
it was blind it could not see that in wounding others it also wounded itself whenever we sin
against others we sin against ourselves also then all frightened louisa said i found myself back
inside of myself all alone without my jesus that he's told her she's inseparable with him
and with the nail in my heart that the one whom i loved had departed from me leaving me alone and
abandoned which is absolutely not true it's just where she's at in her feelings it's not fact
and when i was raving and agonizing because of the pain my sweet jesus moving in my interior
and sighing because of my heart state said my daughter cam yourself cam yourself i am with you
i do not leave you joshua one five and besides how can i leave you look my will is everywhere if you
are in my will i do not know where to go nor do i find a place which i could move away from you he's
told her this many times i would have to render my will limited and gather it in one point in order
to leave you but i can't do that my immensity extends everywhere and my nature renders all that
belongs to me immense so you can't just dwindle down therefore my will is immense my power my love my
wisdom everything all my attributes are immense so how can i leave you if i find you everywhere in
my will therefore be sure that i do not leave you and plunge yourself ever more deeply into the
immensity of my will so let's go on to october the first 1925 and the heading is actually quite
important the divine will is the center of the humanity of jesus one who lives in the divine will
actually lives in the center of the humanity of jesus that heading it deserves a little bit of
thought louisa said i was accompanying the pains of the passion of my sweet jesus according to my
usual way and i offered the very privation of him and the torture it caused me as attestation of my
sorrowful love okay ten out of ten for that and also for his relief and as compassion for his
pains so she's now giving a very good response now while i was doing this my beloved good moved one
arm within my interior raising his right hand and letting rivolids of blood and of light flow from
his fingers over my poor soul which was withered and burned by the powerful blowing of his privation
and with such sadness that jesus himself was shaken and he was moved to compassion wanting to cheer me
and he said my daughter courage do not fear all over the bible 365 times god tells us not to fear
one who lives in my will is in the center of my humanity
that means the fish is living in the center of the water but if you ask the fish where is the
ocean it might be able to answer it even though it cannot live outside of water and we have louisa
here living in the center of the humanity of jesus thinking that he has left her it's amazing
one who lives in my will is notice that is in the center of my humanity because the divine will
is in me like the sun within its own sphere there's these two natures human and divine
even though the rays of the sun invade the earth it never departs from up high from its center
it remains always encircled within its sphere in its majestic throne and while its light reaches
everywhere dominating everything everything serves as its footstool as all await its beneficial light
such was my will within me like the center in the sphere of my humanity and from my sphere
light originated put a little bit of english on that one where did light originate he said from
from me so now you need to go back to the book of genesis and you hear the words let there be light
god said let there be light well jesus is god look at this and from my sphere the light originated
reaching everyone and every place this had been the first act of man to reject my supreme will
therefore it was appropriate that my humanity the second atom would take the first step towards
the divine will centralizing this eternal will within me as the center of life and bringing it to man
once again through my life my works my pains and so on as we say in the liturgy through him
with him and in him so through my life my work my pains so that man might return to his creator
placing himself in the order in which he had been created so the job we have to do is to let the
lord reorder us that's reordering our intellect memory will our hearts our motivations our desires
and the body will follow do you see then my daughter jesus said the soul who lives in my will is
in the center of my humanity and everything i did and suffered is all around her it's there for her
help so if we're living in the center of jesus everything that he has done is available to us
if she is weak the divine will let ministers strength my strengths to her if she's shaded my
blood washes her and embellishes her my prayers sustain her my arms hold her tightly and cover her
with my works that's one of the sentences you need to take out of the book and write it
somewhere where you can really remind yourself of it in some everything is for her defense
and help now he tells us all over these writings that everything he did in redemption was for our
healing our help our encouragement to get us on the road to get us going to heaven it's all helping
us this is why the thought of my pains is as though natural to you because since you live in my will
these pains and everything else that jesus did surrounds you like many clouds of light and of grace
within the sphere of my humanity my will placed my works my steps my words my blood my wounds my
pains and everything i did as though on the way in order to call man and to give him sufficient
aids and means to save him and to make him come back again into the womb of my will
if my will had wanted to enter the field on its own in order to call man he would have been
frightened because we were down far too low on the level of the flesh instead he said
i wanted to call him with everything i did and suffered like many enticements pushes
encouragement and means to make him return into my arms so everything i did and suffered is the
carrier of man to god i think that's beautiful and what i want to give you there is is john 151
the stairway to heaven everything i did and suffered is the carrier of man to god now one who lives in
my will by living in the center of my humanity takes all the fruits of everything i did and
suffered we have to make sure we do actually take them and we have to make sure that we actually
enter the order of creation and my will fulfills in him the full purpose for which he was created
is just wonderful others then who do not live in my will find the means to be saved but don't enjoy
all the fruits of creation and redemption so we're in a very privileged position
while the my beloved jesus was saying this louisa said i said to him my love i don't know
you tell me that i live in your will and then you leave me and what a hard march you make me go through
as you leave me everything changes for me i myself no longer recognize myself everything
dies in me the light dies the love the good you alone maintain the beating of life in this poor
soul i want to give you john 15 5 without me you can do nothing now louisa is in a very special
position that her very living even physically is a miracle and so as jesus withdraws his obvious
presence from her she notices that all her ability to live also goes so i can't be hard on her then
in baby saying she shouldn't be calling on him so much to come back she has to because her very
life depends on it she says everything dies see then in what a hard and painful condition you leave
me now he has told her in a couple of volumes before this that she is experiencing a process of
dying and rising and dying and rising all the time which is her incredible intercession for
the human race to try and get the human race to rise in the divine will well please have pity on me
she said and don't leave me anymore for i can take no more and while i wanted to say more jesus
saying at it my daughter be quiet don't go on any further your words wound my heart
because he's living within her he feels it all oh how i would like to remove from your heart this
nail which is so difficult that i might leave you i too know that for one who loves me this nail
is unbearable now i take it as red that none of us are at the level that louise is at
but could you live without him you couldn't i would have no meaning without him it's all about him
and once we have learned in any way to love him that's it you're spoiled for life nothing else will
ever fill that gap nothing he alone can fill it so there's a sense of which you know i understand
what louise is saying so jesus said i know too that for one who loves me this nail is unbearable
it kills one continuously without pity therefore lay down the thought that i might leave you you
should be convinced that instead of leaving you i in fact penetrate more deeply into you
and i remain silent in the little ship of your soul there's a big revelation big big revelation
just as the lord stays continuously with us absolutely hidden in the eucharist unrecognized
by most in the same way he's hidden in the depths of our being and the more we go towards complete
union with him the more that presence is there but for most of us it's hidden very few people
let me start this differently the saints tell us that there are two major roots to god one is you
know visions and revelations and the lord's visitations and he talks to you and all the rest of it that's
called the way of light and it's the most dangerous because this lots of temptations and satan can
really trip you up the other one is the way of darkness it's the darkness of pure fate you're
not getting visions you're not getting revelations you're not getting anything that appears special
to you or anybody else but it's the safe path and it's the path that's given to nine out of 10
of those who follow the lord it's a safe path and what the lord does is he penetrates deep
into the very depths of our being and we know he's there and yet at the same time
we can be questioning it it's really it's really incredible just let him be taken away and you'd
know what an unfathomable emptiness had entered your being i remain silent in the little ship of your
soul as beautiful and that little ship is traveling on the great waters of the divine will
now i want to give you mark four versus 38 to 40 and this is so true he said that nothing has
changed nothing has moved within you the preparations that are there are still there everything is in
order so much so that it's enough for my will to want it and i give a little spin to the preparations
that are there and i'm quickly with you and besides how can i leave you one who does my will and lives
in it watch this maintains the bonds of creation that exist between the creator and the creature
they maintain the bonds of redemption and the bonds between the sanctifier and those who are
being sanctified and you say to yourself what bonds are these my will seals all these bonds
and renders the soul inseparable from me hmm well a bond is something that holds two things together
therefore he said be sure that your jesus doesn't leave you but he has to explain the bonds
now while he was saying this i saw as though many threads of light
that bound my heart some of them were bound to all of created things others were bound to
everything that jesus did which of course is creation and redemption and others to the sacraments
and so on to sanctification may everything be for the glory of god now what he's talking about here
is that when we enter into this inseparable union with jesus and we keep doing the the prayers
that he actually wants us to do and our responses he he makes these threads between us and creation
so he's he's building all the time and we know that every single act we do is building with it
it's really really amazing so let's start on october the fourth 1925 this is an answer to the
question what does the i love you do for you are you just being childish and saying i love you i
love you i love you so first of all in the first paragraph he's going to talk about
how you grow spiritually and how you produce fruit very important so louisa said i was
fusing myself in the most holy will of god according to my usual way and while going around in the
divine will i place my i love you upon everything i wish that my jesus would see or hear nothing but
my i love you and through this i love you of mine and while repeating the sing song of my i love
you i thought to myself it really shows that i'm a little child i can do nothing but the little
story of part she has learned and then what good comes to me by repeating i love you i think this
is one the occasions where it's not louisa's problem that the the question is given to her so
that she will answer a doubt for us why do i do all these i love you so what good comes to me by
repeating i love you i love you over and over again but while i was thinking of this my adorable
jesus came out from within my interior showing my i love you impressed everywhere in all of his
person on his lips his face his forehead his eyes in the middle of his breast on his back on the back
and in the center of the palms of his hands on the tips of his fingers in some everywhere and
with the tender tone he said to me my daughter aren't you happy that none of the i love yous
that came out of you got lost but they all remain impressed in me and then do you know what good
comes to you by repeating them you must know that when the soul decides to do some good
or to exercise a virtue she forms a seed of that virtue i love this now it's gorgeous
by repeating those acts she forms the water which to water the seed in the earth of her heart
and the more often she repeats them the more she waters the seed and the plant grows beautiful
and green in such a way that it quickly produces the fruits of that seed Galatians 5 22 fruits of
the spirit on the other hand if she is slow in repeating many times the seed remains suffocated
if it comes out at all or it grows thin and it never gives fruit poor seed without enough water to grow
my sun does not rise over that seed to give it fecundity maturity and a beautiful color
for its fruit because it's not fertile on the other hand by always repeating those same acts
the soul contains much water with which to water the seed my sun rises over that seed every time
it sees it being watered and it delights so much knowing that it has much strength in order to grow
and to make its branches reach up to me and in seeing its many fruits i pick them with pleasure
and watch this i rest under its shadow wow you go to the scriptures and from from genesis people
rest under the shadow of great trees you know in a hot country and so on if you go to sam 57 verse
one shelter under the shadow of my wings if you go to the gospel jesus said i wanted to gather you
as a hen gathered her chicks under her wings but in the divine will for somebody who is putting
there i love you on the whole of the universe and into all of redemption and sanctification
jesus says that the divine will breasts in your shadow i think that's amazing
i want to give you the teaching we've just read in a little rhyme that you probably know about
because i learned it when i was a child and the rhyme is so an act reap a habit
so a habit reap a character so a character reap a destiny they've known always that one act
doesn't make you patient or kind it doesn't bring you to the fullness of love one act doesn't do it
it requires many acts and those many acts have got to become a habit if a character is to be produced
and when this character full of grace and virtue is produced then you have a destiny in heaven
wonderful destiny okay so there the repeated acts so in the next paragraph then jesus speaks about
if we continue giving our i love you that the tree of the divine will grows in us it's beautiful
so repeating your i love you for me procures for you one the water with which to water and form
the tree of love and this isn't very important because god is love the kingdom of god is a kingdom
of love the only thing you can take from the earth the only baggage allowance is love
you will be judged on love back to 25 and the only thing you can take into heaven is love
therefore a tree of love has got to actually grow in us and produce the fruits of the spirit
otherwise we're not recognizable as citizens of heaven so repeating your i love you
procures for you the water with which to water and form the tree of love number two repeating
patience waters and forms the tree of patience number three to water and form the divine and
the eternal tree of my will this is extremely important if you have your book in front of you
please color this nothing can be formed with one single act but with many and repeated act
and the example i would give you there is knitting a jumper one stitch won't make the jumper
it requires thousands of them and you have to get many many many stitches just to get the sleeve
and it takes perseverance for you to put that jumper together stitch by stitch by stitch
nothing can be formed with one single act only your Jesus has the power of forming
all things and the greatest things with one single act because he has the creative power
but the creature or the individual person by dint of repeating the same act forms the good
that she wants to do bit by bit now the other example that men would probably prefer is that
you build a house brick by brick one brick won't do the house
so she has to do it bit by bit
fourthly through habit that good or that virtue becomes her nature
that means the habit creates a character and the character creates a destiny
through habit that good or that virtue becomes her nature and the soul becomes the possessor of it
and it forms all of her fortune you have a destiny
and this is this happens also in the natural order so now he's going to explain it he's going to give
an example no one becomes a teacher by having read vowels in consonants once or only a few times
but by repeating them constantly to the point of filling his mind his will and his heart
so that that knowledge which is needed in order to be able to teach others
no one feels satisfied when they when they don't eat bite after bite the food that is
needed in order to satisfy the body no one harvests the seeds if he does not repeat who knows how many
times his work in the field and so would many other things to repeat the same act is a sign
that one loves appreciates and wants to possess that very act in which he repeats
therefore repeat repeat repeat repeat incessantly incessantly incessantly don't ever get tired
in this final section here we're going to look at Jesus's prayers acts everything he has provided
for us that we can use in intercession for others afterwards i found myself outside of myself and
my sweet Jesus carried me around through all those places in which while being on earth he had
operated suffered prayed and also cried so now she by locates to israel everything was there and
in act everything that he had done and my beloved good said to me my daughter daughter of my supreme
volition my will wants to make you take part in everything everything you see are all the works
that i have done while being on earth which my will keeps suspended within itself because souls
don't want to dispose themselves to receive them partly because they don't know what i've done
see number one here are the prayers that i did at night covered with bitter tears and with
ardent sighs for the salvation of all they're all in waiting to give themselves to creatures
in order to give them the fruits that they contain door for he said enter into them cover yourself
with my tears clothe yourself with my prayers so that my will may accomplish in you the effects
which are in my tears prayers and sighs and won't that make prayer an awful lot easier
to enter into the prayers of Jesus and just echo his prayers to the Father not only that he said
my will keeps as though lined up within itself the pains of my childhood and all of the interior
acts of my hidden life which are tragedies of grace and of sanctity all the humiliations
glories and pains of my public life and the most hidden pains of my passion now this is what
Jesus went to great trouble to reveal to louisa so that the rest of us would be able to move in
there and touch them and make them available for others everything is suspended he said
the complete fruit has not been taken yet by souls and i am waiting for the ones who will
live in my will so that they may no longer be suspended that means everything we've just been
saying but they may pour themselves out upon the souls living in my will to give them their
complete fruit only the ones who must live in my will will make my goods no longer be suspended
therefore enter into my every act and pain that my will may be fulfilled in you that is completely
between you and me i do not want suspended things i watch this now if you have your book with you
this definitely needs to be colored nor do i tolerate being unable to tell you what i want
this is why i want to find my own will in you so that nothing may oppose what my will itself
wants to give you and while jesus was saying this i moved from one act of jesus to the other
notice of her immediate obedience and i remained as though transformed covered with his own acts
prayers tears and pains who can say what i experienced i hope that blessed jesus will give me the grace
to respond and to fulfill his adorable will in me and in all amen so that's what we're doing for
tonight but please do enter into the prayers and the acts and the intercessions of jesus
as he has described here in his infancy his childhood his public life his passion death
resurrection bring it all to fruition in the divine will so thank you for listening and i'm
glad we're back sharing again god bless